I'm curious and really I'm working in
the image processing team mainly on
neural networks and color processing and
today I mean in talking about colors I
took is playing with colors
good morning I'm Julia from the image
processing team and I decided this year
not to had the typical talk over the
last couple of years in every conference
that was about machine learning and your
microphone images because I mean there
are more of them and you probably
attended them here and there also at
this conference so I say why don't we go
back to back to basics and this is
something that we've been in various
degree degrees having in the language in
this a long time there's some new stuff
some old stuff but I never really
presented comprehensively the this topic
of colors at this conference so I said
like why not let's do it and so the idea
is to just yeah sure that's a very good
idea this or more more MORE who wants
more hundred fifty and a fifty one okay
so the idea is like let's start from the
basic what what is the color like we use
them we have images we we have all this
kind of convolution layer starting
properties classifying localizing things
transfer style but like in the end we
are displaying something some what we
see so so what what's behind the color
on the screen I mean what's actually is
a color I think that almost everybody
here from a sort of scientific on the
ground even a little can can say that
color color is light is the
electromagnetic light that just is
emitted or bounces against something and
then reaches your your eyes and we had
sensors here like they're organic but
still sensors so we we see according to
the frequency that the incoming
frequency we see different things
oh this is not in scale of course it
would be like pretty pretty difficult to
see the difference but but I mean the
idea is like the lower frequencies we
have to state with colors like red or
like blue and then sorry or all green
then we move
threw like this kind of blueish green
and then we have blue and then have
violet which is not in this spectrum but
trust me and and many disappears I mean
above and below because we cannot see
our sense that doesn't work
so here the physics incline like this is
the formula for the energy of a photon
and like okay Omega is just a rescale
frequency so like it depends according
to the planck constant the energies are
aptly proportional to that the frequency
so like we see more energetic light as
blue and messengered like us red so the
idea is that we associate with the
school like visible spectrum to the
frequency or like I started with
frequency because it's directly
proportional to energy but like actually
what we use typically in color sciences
we talk about wavelengths of Kalos so
when you say that the length of light is
something it's refers to this so like
bigger wavelength is is a grad lower
wavelength is a green blue and then
inviolate like higher higher energetic
and you can see like this an experiment
that you can do like if you take a prism
and you shine white light it it splits
it according to the split according to
the frequency so so you see different
different colors coming out so this is
the classical experiment to show you
like white color is made of colors of
different frequencies and so but why
okay dynamic but not everything emits
light on on its own so like when we
actually see Conners from from objects
we are seeing reflected light and the
light which is reflected is generated by
something else this something else
typically outside before the
technological era who was the Sun and is
still the Sun for like what most of the
time so like we need if you want to
understand how how these scholars are
produced we need a model for the light
which is emitted from the Sun and the
classical model here is is to use a
simple blackbody radiator the you may
know that every every like substance
emits light according to its temperature
following a low which is this one and
the nice thing about this though is it's
very very simple because the the amount
of the amount of light that you emit at
every wavelength is only depending on
your temperature so like we as a human
being we also meet light we we cannot
see it because it's an infrared light
and our sensor in the eye it doesn't
work but if you use an infrared camera
you you can easily see human beings
shining and your phone emits lights that
at different temperature it's it's very
cold so like it's even lower temperature
and and other things emit at different
frequencies but we may or may not see so
basically this is a representation of
the emission spectrum of a blackbody
like for each each wavelength you have
the the emitted energy and you see that
if I vary by temperature you have the
average color they're given the
temperature and and then you see that
like I painted that black where we don't
see it and then I put real colors where
we can't see them and you can see that
as I move the the peak of emission
changes and equity our Sun temperature
is around 6,000 Kelvin is a little less
and it's not by chance that what we can
see in terms of wavelength of light is
exactly around the peak array of
emission of the Sun I mean nature is not
damp we have optimized our sensors to
see what's actually is is is hit by the
most element element in the humanity
radiation from the Sun and so basically
this is this is how like lights comes to
be and comes to us are you I wanted to
have a little exponent here because it
was a colleague of mine asked me
something like two weeks ago is like I
want to do the classical calculation
about what's the color of the sky and it
didn't turn out so we look at that
together and I asked him permission so I
can I can show ya so basically we can we
can use we can use what we've just seen
to just perform a simple calculation for
example I can get from let's let's hope
it's work internet works yeah
No ok so I can query for the temperature
of a Sun which is this is like roughly
6000 Kelvin and then I can sorry
mmm no no I don't want that delayed
because I want to pre compute the
function given a temperature so I want
to remove it temper of the dependency
just we shine the sunlight and we just
want the dependency on the wavelength so
we define this this formula and then
this is what we tried at the beginning
yeah so like you you get what's the
average frequency that that arrives to
to to earth basically and that's pretty
pretty low and unsurprisingly it's our
exact wavelength and surprisingly we
don't see that but that's a very like
stupid calculation we just want to
restrict ourselves to stop what you can
see so we check online and the typical
range of visible light is from like 400
nanometers to 700 so if we try to
integrate that we get different
wavelength and we get a different color
which is disappointing I mean I don't
know if you can see that it's not the
color of the sky but then that there's a
catch like the light of the Sun is
indeed this spectrum that we have seen
above here but then it hits the
atmosphere and in the atmosphere you
have a lot of air and things and if
you're fizzes you know that this red
light scattering happening so we need to
change a bit the spectrum of the light
to take this into account and because we
want to measure up to near the diffused
light from from the Atma from the
particles in the India atmosphere so we
we divide by lambda to the power 4 which
is roughly the same order of the over a
light scattering and we try this
integral again and now we get much
better color I would say so it works
and we can make it even better because I
this is just like average frequency but
as I say we have sensors in the eye and
they measure things and they are not
flat I mean they're in measure response
of the eyes of light at every frequency
that we can see so I can use what is
called by color matching function more
about this later to to basically compute
a much better estimate of the color
brain we can see and I'm pretty happy
with this final result like this looks
like
good good hue for the color of the sky
so like already already just by by
knowing how colors come come to be you
can already do all sorts of computation
with them and a nice little essence
devious how things come to be
so if you if you go back to the - that
black body concept then then we can use
the machinery but created - to compute
the the temporal that we perceive a
sorry we're in the color but we perceive
a different temperatures and this is
unscaled like it's just very
chromaticity more about this later and
and then we can plot this and you see
like here basically is like the
temperature of this blackbody concept
but you have a temperature that creates
like light indirectly and setting upon
we can see that when it is like this
kind of reddish here and we can see and
raising the temperature changes and this
is what happens I for example when you
have like red stars blue stars is
basically you move across this line and
and after us in the temperatura say -
brights and again we cannot see anything
hey thanks for asking I have a slide
about that and so just to wrap this up
we we have we have seen that like the
certain temperature of light creates
color so we can simulate the temperature
of light by changing color we can do the
reverse and this is a typical
image processing technique like
photography technique that you want to
change a white point of your image so
like here I put the temperature slider
and I use this function color balance to
to change the the white of the image to
go to another temperature and I can I
can simulate like lower temperature to
have a kind of a morning or evening
effect when the Sun is rather or I can I
can simulate an overcast sky when it's
like a bit colder by just by changing
and this is like only this constant
temperature applied the white collar's
yet this is not real the shadows are all
wrong and as you can see and okay so
let's quickly go back to to color
numbers and and how we we put I mean we
have computed light and frequency and
spectra but we need the commit numbers
to display so very quickly I spoke about
sensors in VI we had 3 I mean we have
four one is sensitive to just brightness
but it's not relevant to our discussion
so we have these three sensors but this
is the response curve of a sensor and
you can see that if we look at the
spectrum one is mostly sensitive around
the blue light and the other two like
it's one like around green light and the
on one Peaks little shorter than red
light
so like RGB not by chance and so
basically this is the data raw data that
comes in ok intermission if one of those
doesn't work you have color blindness
and it's surprisingly more common that
you think and this is a simulation that
we do with the image effect function of
like how people may perceive colors when
one of the receptor is damaged or absent
you have to move to a different space
you have to move to it to the space of
color defined by these three functions
and then you can like inactivate or
reduce one of them and actually this is
if you are doing application like UX
design or something like that this is
very very important because like 5% of
male human being they have a deuteron
Opia that means that they see like the
middle picture and your
wonderful color palettes is basically
useless because you cannot distinguish
like anything I'm not on the plot so we
talk about the eye but actually we all
know about like RGB so like we need a
way to display those this incoming light
with not so many numbers like we pick
three because we have these three
receptors so people in the 20s started
like making experiments and so one
experiment was very like foundational
was like a collimation experiment the
idea was basically let's take a disc
split it in two and on one side I just
put a random color and on the other side
I put a color combination as I take like
one blue light one green light and one
red light that I will define like
specific wavelengths monochromatic light
and then I have three knots and ask
people like like run up if I could
people in say okay look at look at one
half and like tune things to match the
second half to the first one so basic
idea is like if this works then we don't
need a complicated like infinite
dimensional spectrum to tell you what
color is something we can just use three
colors and we can we can make that like
in relation to the human perception just
by having this this measure so this was
done and and these these three functions
were like the product over I think seven
to eight people seven to ten sorry I
don't remember where involving this
experiment not too many think how
important it is and so we'd like to
things and then everything was tabulated
and this is how you take a spectrum and
you generate an RGB color basically
according to one standard and if you
think about that it's basically you're
taking something which is in in an
infinite dimensional space and you're
projecting that on a three dimensional
space basically this is a three
dimensional GB space and every color now
is a point but every color now is a
point in this cube this free coordinate
going from zero to one then you have
like zero zero zero is black one one one
is white and all sort of things okay
this this space was like was good and
they saw it and it was good
but well it has problems like some of
them like okay it was it 30s people are
doing computational by hand and if you
notice like all these functions are are
going negative and you can ask me okay
how it's possible like they were just
like turn is this knobs and and and
tuning tuning light from like no lights
to Maxima lights so how can it go
negative
turns out tough luck if you want to do
this just by adding light it doesn't
work so the idea was okay if let's not
throw this away because it's promising
so let's say if you cannot really match
the color by by tuning those three
primaries then we we allow you to add a
little bit of one on the three to to the
to the color data to the target color
but you have to match and so we say okay
when we do that we say that we we
basically subtract this color from from
the from the matching process so this is
why all those functions are way negative
and this tells you this really is
impossible to match every color we can
see just by adding three lights and this
was a problem in the thirties because
people were doing computation by hand
and they didn't really want to help
function that could go negative was like
if I've been turns out positive was okay
good check like they did we didn't want
this problem also these these three
functions they don't really mean
anything so they the idea was like let's
let's do a transformation and create a
space that suits our needs is that the
official space is imaginary space so we
can have all the properties that you
want so the ideals are okay one
coordinate we want that to simulate the
the brightness of the color and that was
like sort of I guess it's not a it's not
a given but I don't want to get into
that certain other like mathematical
restriction and also this positively
defined thing so the result was this XYZ
space that you probably don't know but
is used everywhere when you convert
colors because it's kind of a hub space
so this space here you can define any
color even color that you don't see it
doesn't it's also strictly between 0 and
1 you can put any number here and it
will be something not necessarily
meaningful and this is just a matrix
information on the previous function so
the cube that we saw here
now we live in a different vector space
and it's just this kind of steel thing
and then you can define it yet another
transformation which allows me to answer
the previous question is that a given
but why was like of a central coordinate
here was picked to be the the brightness
it's called luminance here I can mean I
can take that away and the rest will
tell me it's fixed luminance what the
color is called chromaticity is like
blue because of blue red yellow so you
can normalize things project on a plane
and you get something like this whether
the vertical direction you know is very
clear is how bright the color is and the
reason the direction at constant
brightness you have all the different
colors so you can then project on 2d and
if you work with color sometimes have
seen this is called from a DC diagram
these are at the boundary of the
frequency but we can see that
monochromatic frequencies we can see if
you combine them you get all the colors
and you can immediately see that if you
pick three points to create your color
system like a monitor you cannot
reproduce every color that's that's
that's not solvable like if you want
three colors is a triangle and this
shape here is not a triangle so this is
you have to balance between how many
colors you want to represent how much if
you have a bite how much steps you want
to have inside of your triangle so I
mean it's it's your choice how do you
want to do that and there are many
choices actually out there you can have
different spaces to work with I think
now Apple is boasting some new color
space for the monitors which is richer
but yeah it depends on your recording a
lot of things so okay these are 3d
things and oh but this shape is
different i subtly change
reference base so that's yet another
space because people say okay we have
like this is cool like we can invent new
spaces let's go on I mean we can have
one space for everything one space to
fit them all okay so before I move this
one like why should you care about this
anyway one example to show you why so I
had this image here with two colors and
we can do something super simple like
let's take the mean of these colors I am
blurring the using mean filter to blur
the the middle area so you see
Green and then goes to red but is kind
of I mean my mother is even better but
it's kind of dark in the middle and why
is that because I get in if I don't know
about what space I'm working with I I
don't know what's happening and actually
when I took about RGB I forgot one
important things that it's very
interesting so I put it here he's like
our we had that y-coordinate it was the
brightness but the human eye is not
linear in the energy that comes in like
basically every sensor we have like ears
like I think pressure as well like
vision nothing is Nia because this is
stupid like you wants you want to see a
candle in the night and you want not to
die if the Sun hits you by mistake so
like you don't want a linear response
it's a really bad idea but if we encode
the brightness linearly then we are
missing out because like but the way we
are made we are we are super sensitive
to small differences in dark but we
really don't don't have the same the
same fine-grained perception in in the
highlights so basically colors are
encoded are compressed when when you
compute the RGB value and then to show
you like it have to be quick and to show
you the difference like this is the
linear scale and probably if this is
decent you see a big jump between black
and the rest so colors are not included
this way
if you want to go linearly in the color
space in RGB you move tuk tuk tuk tuk
what you see is something like this you
have this compression factor which is
like roughly 2.2 and now you see that I
mean we can see steel sieve nice
differences in in in the dark and and
this is the trick that is used to
capture to better that the shadows in in
color presentation so okay it may be
important and by okay but back to the
problem like we wanted to compute them
into two over two colors but we were not
working in a linear space maybe we
didn't know but now that we know we can
do the same book hahaha no this is wrong
wrong wrong here now but we know we can
compute the same thing and now it's what
you expect like the color in between red
and green is not like some darkish thing
and inequity according to the space you
are in something
simple as taking the meaning of two
colors beeps completely from the result
like you see but in I'm working here and
then yes please XYZ and that's the line
that connects red and green if you go in
RGB you have this line here but it goes
in the dark and if you move for example
in the hue space a HSB technically you
just follow this maximum saturation
color here but it's not linear at all
so we mean this is very important when
you're when you're thinking like about
numerically both colors and almost over
and if you know about this you can do
your own application like for example
like this is something content that just
uses like image apply to apply different
nonlinear functions to colors so for
example I can say oh the red Channel
make it like high contrast green channel
as well and blue like something like
rock crossfading is cool like low
contrast and now you have like a
different visual effect you can simulate
all sort of like camera filters and and
films and I don't know if you can see
the difference but like it can be quite
dramatic of course like I'm doing the
sample adjustments but like adding some
non-linearity to your to your column
pipeline it's it's very very very
powerful effect so this was a very big
thing I'm almost out so let's try to
finish I show this piece here and I say
that it's subtly I change representation
this is a nama space it's not at RGB
it's not XYZ it's called lab and I
mention it because it's behind many
functions that I wrote in in in color
processing Mathematica and the idea was
a quite like we have this RGB with the
light we had this XYZ which is useful
because it's linear have always sort of
properties and you can define other
things using that and it's good but we
need something that captures color
relations in a way that is similar to
how we human captured them
like we don't think in term of we don't
even think in term of RGB we think in
term of like this color is bright this
color is dark this core is very
saturated this color has a lot of blue
in it so we
was like can we find a combination
linear nonlinear this is nonlinear that
captures better
what is collect perceptually the the
color appears and so the experiment
experiments I think this is from the 60s
and forgot it was like another space was
created that was a no linear combination
of those x y&z values and this is based
way more on how our human eye works
because like we have these three
functions but III show you they're like
the three cones the three receptors
these but actually this not what goes to
our brain the the eye is a very powerful
sensor and that's all sort of
pre-processing of what's coming in and
and the pre-processing it does is very
similar in a similar because it was done
on purpose to how this base is defined
so we have like these three channels in
the eye they are like combined in a
channel which is a mean of them and this
is like how bright something is so we
say one channel we define as the
brightness which is called lightness in
in maybe and is there's no linear so
it's not even a way similar to our our
eye is nonlinear so like you cannot do
linear mixing here but if you move a
step it's it should be similar to what
happens when you move a step in our
perception and then the other okay we
had three coordinates so we need we need
other two and what our eyes is doing is
taking differences so basically is
typical two sensors like you don't want
to give an absolute number is much
better if you stay around zero so the
other two channels are defined as the
whole color of pollen see so it's
basically one channel tells you red
versus green and the other channels
tells you blue versus versus yellow and
this is why physiologically it's very
easy to say that a blue is greener but
it's very difficult to say that the blue
is yellow because if you add yellow you
are removing blue from the same Channel
so like it's not not orthogonal you
cannot do that so the idea was like
let's define a space where we captured
these properties and and here I have an
image and I decompose that in these
three three coordinates and you can see
plotted here so
this leb space is very nice to talk
about colors because like now a vertical
component is how bright a color is if I
say at the center here I have a line
that goes up which are all the grace
case and if I move to the side I can
think about cylindrical coordinates if I
move to the side I add saturation it's
called chroma in this space and if I
move its a hue so basically in this
place like relations are way more
natural to talk about and all our color
function color distance color metrics
are defined starting at least from from
this space so the idea is like let's see
what happens let's see what happens when
I change the something like this image
is very ready oversaturated I want to
reduce it this is when I change the
contrast in RGB contrast makes
everything great basically and if I
increase the contrast in RGB this is
when I use the HHS B which is a
transformation of RGB so I go to
grayscale but this has doesn't help that
doesn't preserve necessarily the how
bright color is and this is using this
lav space so ideally if I reduce this
the the perceived brightness when I move
should be constant I don't know if it
shows is just the saturation component
that is changing so just something as
simple as adjusting an image it has very
different results if you know if uses
specific color space and last example
very very quickly this new function we
added in 12 and you say let's see if you
want to use that 2 / 8 on colors you
want to different use V space defined
distances for example have this plot and
is rasterized I want to change the color
but I cannot be computed because I don't
have a data it's just an image so I can
I can use this this idea of like finding
a good space which is perceptually close
to how we see colors to find for example
I want to partition Colo close to green
and color close to to red and then I
measure these our new functions I
measure masked for this and then what I
do is I just say like everything is
packed for you of course the function
just shift the hue and then you get a
new color and so I think it's
it's done so thank you and sorry for the
long term